[Music]
the u.s is lifting its travel
restrictions for people who are entering
from foreign countries starting november
8th as long as they are fully vaccinated
and can prove it they can enter the us
this affects both air and land border
travelers so here's what you need to
know about the new policy
during the pandemic there were travel
bans imposed by the trump administration
and the new rules that are going into
effect replace those bans starting
november 8th foreign nationals will be
allowed to enter the u.s if they are
fully vaccinated and can show proof of
vaccination they also need to have a
negative cova test taken within three
days if they're traveling by air but
that negative cova test is not necessary
if they're traveling by land
[Music]
the acceptable vaccines are ones that
have been authorized or approved by the
food and drug administration or vaccines
that have been listed for emergency use
by the world health organization so that
includes the pfizer vaccine moderna
johnson johnson as well as astrazeneca
and china's cinepharm and cinevac
vaccines russia's sputnik v vaccine has
not been authorized or approved by the
fda or who
there are limited exemptions to the
rules so those include kids under 18
certain vaccine clinical trial
participants and those with medical
exemptions there are exceptions for
people who need to travel for emergency
or humanitarian reasons but these people
need to get a us government-issued
letter that verifies their urgent need
to travel now there are also exceptions
for people who are traveling on
non-tourist visas from countries with
low vaccine availability and those
countries are determined by the cdc
[Music]
there are also changes for u.s citizens
and lawful permanent residents who are
returning from abroad by air if you are
fully vaccinated you'll need to show
your proof of vaccination as well as a
negative cova test that was taken within
three days but if you are unvaccinated
you will need to show a negative cova
test that was taken within one day
[Music]
so kids who are under 18 are exempted
from the vaccination requirements and
this is because some younger kids are
currently ineligible for vaccination and
the vaccine availability for kids varies
across the globe but kids between the
ages of 2 and 17 do need to take a
pre-departure cova test if they're
flying and that's regardless of their
citizenship if they're traveling with a
fully vaccinated adult they can present
a test that was taken within three days
of departure but if they're traveling
alone or with unvaccinated adults then
they need to present a test that was
taken within one day of departure
[Music]